[Music]
hi everyone welcome to data analytics
3:09 where we're gonna talk about
advanced techniques in cloud data prep
for cleaning your data quick show of
hands quick show hands how many people
here are familiar with cloud data prep
show your hands
ok we've got a good number of you sorry
I can't see cuz lights are right in my
eyes so just today will definitely be an
advanced session we're going to talk
about some of the more challenging
techniques and data prep but we will
start off with a brief overview of cloud
data prep just a level set everyone make
sure everyone's at the same point the
main focus will be talking about the
data prep lifecycle and common
challenges we've seen with our customers
and then we'll talk about specific
scenarios and advanced techniques to
solve them as part of this will of
course be interspersing demonstrations
live with my co-presenter and then at
the end we'll do a brief recap as well
as if we have time some Q&A ok brief
introductions sean ma i'm the product
manager responsible for cloud data prep
i've been with it since the very
beginning with me is cindy Sood
she's the data prep sales engineer for
north america and we're both from
trifecta so as you know Google and try
Factor have partnered for the last few
years to provide you cloud data prep as
a service and it's part of the GCP Big
Data suite together we've we've we've
got thousands of joint companies tens of
thousands of users and millions of data
prep jobs running all around the world
you may ask the question whose trifecta
we're an industry leader in data
preparation as recognized by analysts
and customers and more importantly
together with Google's server list
platform and try fact is easy to use
interface our goal is to make is to help
you get the most value out of your data
okay enough with introductions we'll do
a really quick overview of what where
cloud data prep is and then we'll get
into those scenarios I talked about so
I'm sure everyone here at Google NEX has
access to tons of data right you know
it's coming in all time you already have
you probably have too much more data
than you can handle
the key question though of course
is gaining insight from that data right
regardless of its marketing data IOT
data machine learning training data this
how do you get inside all that data so
cloud data prep is specifically designed
to solve this challenge by providing you
data preparation as a service where you
can visually explore clean and transform
any type of data whether it be semi
structure structured data you name it
you'll be able to work with it in an
easy-to-use interface without having sup
any infrastructure and Sol any VMs or
manage any any systems right our goal is
to make data preparation which typically
takes weeks takes weeks and a lot of
effort to get to do into something that
it takes days if not hours and of course
we want to make this as accessible as
possible to a wide range of users so
there's data scientists I'm sure in
there and the audience data engineers
and data analysts we want to make sure
that everyone can use data preparation
without having to write any code alright
so how does this work very briefly so
well first cover is on how we access
data so data prep has native integration
with your DCP project through I am and
so allows you to access data directly in
bigquery and cloud storage or you can
upload your own files so that way you
can use a self-service interface to then
transform profile cleanse join any of
your data that you need ok now when it
comes down to actually try executing
this at scale cloud data prep uses the
power of data flow in order to easily
and efficiently scale to any region in
the world the last thing I'll note is
that once you've got the data prepared
and refined the question is where do you
want to put it and often the downstream
systems that you'll see here on the
analyze side are gonna be bigquery you
can load it in there for additional
querying you can use it for bigquery ml
you can obviously build reports and data
studio so that that's often end result
for this but just as just as often
you're loading into cloud storage where
you might actually use it as in cloud ml
to train a model ok so these are
different a very high level how data
comes in how its transformed and where
it goes once you're done with it ok last
slide from the introduction is when do
you use cloud air prep what used
Jace's is a good floor now don't get me
wrong clean prepare data is gonna be
useful in many places right who doesn't
who doesn't want to use that but we
found in particular that many of our
customers focus on three particular use
cases where they're most successful with
right the first ones data onboarding
this is where analysts in particular
need to deal with third-party or
external data and they want to integrate
it into their existing pipeline but
because it comes from a third party it
doesn't always conform to their internal
standards in certain formats so it's
actually hard to use and how to automate
so how do you get that standardized
fixed so that you can use it inside next
next is Nexus data science and machine
learning right so this is not just for
analysts all right oftentimes the data
scientists are using our data prep
because if you want to train your model
you really want well what you want well
structure clean data in order to be most
efficient with these projects the last
ones marketing analytics probably most
folks are familiar with this you've got
lots of marketing data that's been
generated especially in the Google suite
but oftentimes you want to gain
additional insight from that marketing
data by combining it with data from
externals from other departments sales
finance support so in order to join the
data aggregated pivoted all those all
those analytics that you need in order
to get the most out of it you'll often
need to manipulate and transform the
data as well in all three cases data
prep is designed specifically to help
you with these three scenarios all right
so that's enough of that intro now we're
going to get into the meat of it and
we're going to talk about common
challenges that customers really have
faced during during the data prep
lifecycle what we'll do is I'll go
through the scenarios and kind of give
you an overview of that and then we'll
switch over to Cindy who actually give
you a live demonstration of each one
okay so let's start off with a data prep
lifecycle this is just a quick diagram
for that right starting off on starting
off on the left here you're starting off
with raw data the goal is then to
discover what's inside of it so that you
can structure and clean the data right
and then clean the data remove remove
obvious data quality errors so that you
can then go
the enriched phase where you're
combining it joining it aggregating
basically transforming the data to what
you need following that then you'll
check your validate it to make sure
conforms to your organization's rules
and definitions and ideally this whole
thing goes into an analytics downstream
analytics like I said data studio or m/l
initiative from there now you might
notice this is a very iterative process
and that's intentional so you can do the
whole thing through the data prep
interface where you're kind of going
through this and cleaning your data
preparing your data to the point where
exact to exactly what you need exactly
what your standards and that the goal
here is for you to do this yourself and
you can do this really rapidly without
any additional additional help now of
course once you get that data into that
format that you need you can then
automate it you can fully automate it
and you can schedule it so it runs
periodically so now you've empowered
your pipeline to run without without you
being there and just updating and your
downstream systems okay so that's the
high level data prep lifecycle now let's
get into the challenges associated with
it
these ones are specific scenarios that
we've seen with customers in different
phases along this journey okay so we'll
start off with the discovery and
structuring phase and while it's really
nice that when the data is in perfect
rows and columns and no issues up front
very often people you get semi
structured data or even unstructured
data and those things in order to get
any value out of that you actually need
to access to individual elements and and
dig into it from there so that's the
first type of problem that we'll be
tackling how do you handle that kind of
nested data following that as part of
kind of the as part of a fter you've
structured the data and you're going
into the cleaning phase you'll often
find that the data doesn't necessarily
have the right format for what you're
looking for often it's actually a
slightly different patterns you're
dealing with in your data and again it's
very hard to make use of data that's all
of different formats of different
patterns inside of it you want to
standardize that or you want to
normalize that into something standard
so that you can actually again perform
your transformations and cleanse it and
next is on the cleaning side while you
can apply common data quality rules
removing nulls checking for checking for
DES checking for statistics I guess the
data
you may be you may also encounter
situations where humans have entered the
data so there's issues with the entry of
the data that it just doesn't fit any
pattern it's really hard to figure out
what those things are so this was
actually before you start doing pivots
and joins on things you want to actually
make sure that that data is cleaned up
and standardized from there from there
what you'll want to do what we'll do
next is then talk about validation of
the data right so remember the whole
goal of this is to make sure that your
data is ready for analytics or
downstream modeling right how do you
know your downstream system will
actually accept your results all these
systems have very specific schemas
they're expecting expecting their data
in certain a certain pattern order right
how do you ensure that that is actually
going to work and of course if you want
to automate all this you have to make
sure that things working consistently
and working each time okay so these are
the four challenges we'll be talking
about and we'll use the following
scenarios to talk through them the first
one is going to be understanding nested
data well will show you how to unpack
and extract information out of deeply
nested elements next is normalizing data
patterns will talk about profiling
understanding those patterns and then
converting them into a standard that
you're looking for when we talked about
inconsistent data we'll talk I will show
you something new with data prep around
clustering and standardizing your data
and the last one validating results will
show you how to compare a match against
your end target so that you know what
you're generating is actually going to
be successful in your end system okay
all right so let's get started
I'll cover the first two nested data and
dated patterns and then like I said will
actually demonstrate some of these so
thinking of nested data all right often
users start off with nested file formats
right so JSON Avro XLS park' that's just
a starting part of that right so let's
take a look at what this looks like I
hope no one can read this cuz this is
actually really painful to understand
it's got a lot of wonderful information
on it but it's really hard to use really
hard to understand really hard to get
any value out of it right so and what's
furthermore even if you found a way to
parse it okay
this is a fairly easy JSON just parse it
you're still left with these type of
elements right complex data elements
often known often seen as arrays or key
value pairs
now this happens not just in files but
this also happens in my query I'm sure
many folks are familiar with nested
nested fields and bigquery you'll see
this type of data nested inside of it
right so you'll still encounter an issue
where hey after I've done the first
level of understanding the data I need
to go deeper than that and finally even
if you get to individual values let's
say for example I get to the search
reference here and I get to my
individual value here well really you
don't want to get you don't want to
access the whole thing you actually want
to get access to some of the embedded
values inside of it right so let's click
or slightly off so what you'll want to
do is you actually want to extract
specific parts in this case here they're
looking for the search term that was
actually used so that's an embedded case
so once again it's still nested data
even though you're down to the
individual value okay so how does how
does the data prep handle this scenario
well first thing out of the box cloud
data perhaps supports those various file
formats and will immediately show you
that data in a row and column format
right so you meaty see these elements
here actual point of this the elements
here the customer you'll see them as
individual columns you'll also see the
data types automatically inferred in the
case where you have nested values this
key value pair here you'll see that
automatically show up here and then the
rest of data broken out from there now
the nice part about this is that because
data prep is understood this as a nested
value it actually can help you on
inspect the contents by simply clicking
on it and you'll be able to see you'll
be able to see the nicely formatted
you'll be able to see the individual
elements nicely formatted so this is
important because hey this is
information I'm looking to have and I
want to actually use this for my
transformations so very easily you will
decide do I want to expand this as rows
or expand this as columns in this case I
kind of want to unnecessarily says
columns so just one click and then I can
just uh nest it and immediately it
becomes five columns
my same data set so now you can for me I
Gration your joins whatever you need now
this is a scenario where I actually
wanted to expand it out but funny enough
a key trick is that not all your data is
relevant one of the one of the hard
parts of nessa data is that then there's
a lot of data inside of it and sometimes
it's all garbage or a lot of it's
garbage and and expanding and unpacking
all of it may be a waste of your time it
may be slow actually may cause more
confusion so there are times where you
actually want to be very much more
specific about the data that you extract
out so I showed you I showed you an
example where I did expand it out but
let me show you one now where I have
again once again I have these key value
pairs here right so this is a that's it
this is a sales order line I've got some
interesting information inside of it
that's great but I don't need all this I
really just want product key and let's
say total sale so what you can actually
do as part of the bar chart up here data
prep allows you to actually select those
individual elements the things that are
highlighted in green just select the
elements that you need and you can
actually tell data prep just to extract
those and it'll just produce those two
columns so you don't need to expand
everything and just kind of blow out
your data set just get the things that
you need because you can see what's
inside of it other things you can do
with with nested elements is that you
can actually perform metadata operations
sometimes you might ask the question
like how many elements are in this
nested value and you want to use that in
your data you can also perform those
operations directly on these objects
okay the last one I want to show is just
talking about those getting that
substring of information so in this
example here I want to grab that search
term order grab that search term so what
you see here is that all you have to do
is highlight the data that you're
interested in so you interact directly
with it highlighted and Gator people
automatically suggest a transformation
that extracts it out for you so you
don't have to deal with the whole string
you're just dealing with what you need
okay all right so now we've got our data
expanded extracted let's take a look at
the data itself and when you're dealing
with data when you're looking at the
individual parts of data you're probably
looking at patterns inside of it right
and I'm sure everyone's familiar with
these these are
pretty standard examples whoops these
are pretty standard examples but of
course it depends on your geography
depends on depends on where your data is
from that you need that that these
standards apply right and problems arise
when you have data coming in from
different places that you're combining
and joining and blending and they have
different formats you can't use it right
like if these things are it's going to
be confusing if you try to combine these
things in the same data set because
they're just different values so the
problem of course is that parsing this
even identifying these patterns inside
data is not easy right everyone who
everyone here familiar with regular
expressions who loves regular
expressions here just quick show of
hands all right so you don't need to be
here for this thanks bye for everyone
else for everyone else this is gonna be
a challenge right this is gonna be a
challenge to not only identify the
patterns that you want but even then can
you imagine how do you convert all the
other patterns into a standard that you
want you're going to be dealing with
multiple regular expressions on that
okay so the nice part is that data prep
actually handles this actually has more
built-in tools specifically around data
patterns what you see here is data prep
data prep taking a column and you can
see additional column details here for a
selected column right not only does it
tell you it's data quality up top it
tells unique value and distribution but
down here it actually breaks out all the
pattern combinations that are within the
data itself and shows you the
cardinality so now you know what's in it
at how often does it appear okay this is
super useful because then you can figure
out which format do you want to
standardize the data on right which
format do you want to normalize and put
things on in this case I although majora
the data is in year year-month-day I
actually wanted to be in month month day
day year year year right so that's kind
of what I want so it's as simple as
clicking on the pattern that you're
interested in and you'll get a
suggestion for transforming that data
that automatically takes all the other
patterns here converts all these other
value patterns here into the pattern
format that you want and all the syntax
is handled on the covers so no regular
expression for you
sorry whoever a few people who wanted
this know regular expressions for you
okay at this point it's probably enough
of me talking you probably wanna see
this in action so I'm gonna head over to
Cindy so she can show you to you in the
product all right thanks Shaun okay so
here we are in the cloud data prep
homepage and under my recently updated
items I'm just going to choose this
sales data flow when I do that it takes
us into a flow view and think of the
flow as a project and just a way to
organize your work
I've already registered a data set here
in this flow I can select it to see more
details over here on the side so we'll
see that this is a JSON file and it
resides in GCS and there's additional
metadata here as well now I've already
started doing some transformations so I
have some transformation logic in my
recipe that's attached to the data we're
gonna choose to edit the recipe and
we're gonna add more transformation
logic when we do that we're brought in
to what we refer to as a transformer
grid and you're presented with rows and
columns of your data now I want you to
keep in mind when we looked at the
details of that data set it was a JSON
file remember that and you notice how
data prep has automatically unnecessary
and columns for you that's pretty cool
we've also dumped some really other
great things too
so you're also presented with the
profile of your data so we do that with
these bar charts and histograms and
that's for every single column that you
have and we also give you this quality
bar which is kind of nice as well and
this is based on the inferred data type
that data prep alone for a data type for
you when you load data so we're gonna
give you a quality bar that will tell
you how many valid or mismatched values
you have present so what's the first
thing you notice there's a big red flag
on this
in this data here so the first thing I
notice are these red sections of the
quality bar so it's saying you know come
take a look at me there's something
wrong here so for an example under
currency key my data type is inferred as
an integer now I can show that I have
valid values present by the Green Green
section of that quality bar and then I
have mismatched values present as well
so this tells me that I have some data
in here that's actually not an integer
so it Flags us and it's a really nice
visual cue to say there's issues with
the data to deal with that I'm just
going to click on it so you can interact
with these histograms and the quality
bars and when I do that I'm basically
interacting with the data so when you
interact with the data what we're going
to do is we're going to come up with
this predictive interactions so data
prep has a predictive interaction engine
based on your interaction and the data
you're looking at you're gonna get these
suggestions over here the first
suggestion that I get was to delete
these rows I don't really want to delete
these rows what I want to do is I want
to deal with this data so I'm gonna come
down here to this set suggestion and I
have this set suggestion that says set
the mismatch values to zero when I
choose it I get a really nice preview
before I actually add that logic to my
recipe so it helps you make decisions on
whether this is something you actually
want to do or not so this is fantastic
so I actually do want this so I'm just
going to hit add you see a nice cleaned
up quality bar right here that logic is
added to my recipe now you can also
interact with the bar charts of the
histograms as well as interacting
directly with the data so here I'm going
to select this comma and my customer
name because I want to split out the
last name from the first name so all I
have to do is interact with that comma
again I get suggestions over here
I got a split suggestion as the first
one it wants me the first suggestion is
just to say okay it's any delimiter but
I'm gonna specify the comma as the
delimiter again we had a nice preview
this is exactly what I want I'm just
going to add that
now we're going to come over here to
this sales order line now this is a bit
trickier so here the data type is an
array now an array and data prep as many
of you probably know is just a list of
items or a group of elements I'm going
to expand to look at this
so not the prettiest thing to help
visualize I'm going to search my rows
just for an open curly bracket so when I
do that I can see the start of each
element or each item in this array so
this is really helpful because I can
visualize it but what I really need to
do here is inspect the information
that's associated with this sales order
lines and I have to get each of these
individual elements into their own
unique row so that's really easy to do a
data print all I'm gonna do is come over
here to the sales order line select it
again we do get some details over here
about the data as well as suggestions
I'm gonna come down to this flattened
array values into new rows I'm gonna
select that it says convert arrays in
the sales order line to rows and what
that does and you can see in the preview
is it's gonna take each element in that
array those lists of items and put it
into its own rows and I did it with just
the click of a button and you can see
all of these elements from that list put
into their own row as well as all of the
other relevant data associated with that
row is populated so I'm just gonna add
this it's exactly what I want I'm gonna
add that to my recipe you come back to
that column we have a new data type we
have an object the object is basically
these key value pairs so you can see
that because you can expand the data and
you can see all of these keys here and
all the values associated with the keys
now as Shawn had talked about we don't
want to extract all of that
information I'm only interested in a
couple of items within this sales order
line so what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to extract just a couple of these
key value pairs and to do that I'm going
to come to the histogram I'm gonna
select this bar chart that represents
the product key and then the bar chart
that's select that represents the unit
price we get a nice preview the
suggestion of course is to unnecessary
rows it's exactly what I want I'm gonna
add it and now basically I have expanded
my data the rows and the columns by just
flattening and then extracting the
relevant information so now I'm done
pulling out the information that I'm
most interested in that look really easy
it's just you know half a dozen steps or
so well Shawn if you were paying
attention you would see that it was only
two steps all right I'm gonna continue
with this data because over here in
order in the order date I see that I
still have some mismatch values and I
need to finish prepping my data so again
I could just select this red section to
see what's mismatched you then are
you're given all of the rows when you
select that it's going to highlight all
of the rows that are mismatched value
and I can kind of visually see right
here that I just have different date
formats so what I really want to do with
this column is to get everything into
the same date format again it's pretty
easy to do this in data prep I'm gonna
select that column over here are those
details again and then we have this
section that's called patterns now I can
choose to show pattern details well it
will give you these patterns right here
we will tell the number the number of
rows and then you get a little sample of
data as well
so I actually want to go month date a
year year year year I'm gonna choose
that pattern now again I just interacted
with the data I get these suggestions
over here on the right panel the first
suggestion is keep rows that's actually
what we're seeing but I'm gonna come
down to this convert rows and if you
look here it's converting values like
these three that I don't want to that
one that I actually selected in the
patterns so three to one in one step so
I'm gonna hit add and when I do that
this gets updated with the standardized
format that I selected pretty nice okay
so I was able to profile identify the
pattern of interest change it and then
validate because if you look now we have
that quality bar here and it's all valid
values so that's the end of the first
part of the demo we're gonna go back to
Shawn and he's gonna talk about a couple
more I think there were two people here
who are sad you didn't do regular
expressions oh okay so we're moving on
to next two examples with inconsistent
data and results validation we just
covered patterns so what the hell is
inconsistent data supposed to mean well
that's actually specifically data that
doesn't really conform to any patterns
so quick example here of here's a
company that of course humans have
entered right Acme Inc right you have
slightly different variations of the
data you see one with periods and - I
think spell checker kicked in and just
rename this to acne and then we've got
you know nice formatting bulbs and
quotes that you have inside of this
right so while we can all recognize this
is probably all the same company not so
great for your data and not so great if
you're going to analysis on this right
so it's really hard to pick this up of
course the goal is then the standardized
this to single establish values so that
you can make effective use of joins and
aggregations because you do want Acme
Inc to show up four times right as one
time as opposed
to four different companies inside okay
so this is something new that we've
added to data prep recently is the
ability to cluster and define is the
ability to cluster your data into groups
based on clustering algorithms there's
something we released just a few weeks
ago and in this example here what you
see is that we have several different
clustering algorithms now that will that
will grab the data that will access the
data sorry that will take the data in a
given column and it showed to you kind
of how many rows show up in a for a
given given instance of that data kind
of group them all together for you there
are different ways you can group the
data based on comparing values closest
spelling sometimes pronunciation and
that's really important because the
trick to all this is that you don't want
to apply just one algorithm when you're
defining your groups you actually want
to apply multiple algorithms on this the
reason why is you want to capture as
many of these inconsistency as possible
so you can standardize them so for
example I could apply additional
additional algorithms on this multiple
on them and you'll see more come out
this one I apply was pronounciation so
you'll see things like acne and acne
right these pronounced similarly so you
actually want to include them into your
group it just makes things a lot easier
for you to then standardize it and go
forward from there and you can type in
what you want your end result to be
now all this said wonderful algorithms
that are you know what cost of making
better and better it's never ever gonna
be perfect so one of the nice part of
being able to interact with the data and
actually see this is that you can now
also identify when there are exceptions
to the rule so now as an example where
the cluster ring because of the
pronunciation it got it captured one too
many in this case I was just looking for
BB construction but not BB construction
that's not what I wanted
so you actually will be able to go into
data prep select that exception just
highlight it and say I don't want to
include this so I can still standardize
on everything else so it also captures
exceptions in addition to the standard
set okay so now we're at a point where
we've gone through most of the
challenges we've got you know we've
we've we've addressed this structured
and formatted data we've off made sure
that we've cleanse mode cleanse the data
you probably perform a bunch of
transformations a bunch of
transformations to
you pivot and pivot the data apply
formulas the last one we want to cover
again was the data validation how do you
know that what you just built is
actually gonna be useful downstream so
when it comes to the target you'll often
see examples like this where the targets
have a very well-designed schema this is
an example of a bigquery table
everyone's familiar with this column's
data types constraints
pretty-pretty sent in that regard right
and most of the time you're you know
when you're preparing data you probably
have a good sense of what you're looking
for you're going to you know go manually
compare or you're gonna remember it off
of memory what you want and you decide
ok I think is what I wanted I'm gonna go
ahead and publish this to again I'm
gonna use bigquery in this example and
oops
bigquery greets you with a very specific
and accurate error message and while
it's well it's got all the information
you want it's actually very difficult to
parse and figure out what went wrong
right you may have going back and forth
trying to figure out well what's wrong
with my data prep what's wrong in the
bigquery table you kind of want to go
back and forth between the two and
figure that thing out I will note that
this this while you see this error
message in bigquery you see the same
problem with files as well it's actually
kind of worse because they don't tell
you what the scheme is supposed to be so
you won't find out until you kind of
pass it along and you get bad data
well the good thing is data prep allows
you to do this comparison much much more
easily and you achieve that by comparing
the data comparing the target directly
in the data set itself so what you can
do is you can actually import the target
here import the target here directly
into the data set and it will
automatically align against the data
that you're working with so you can do
that direct comparison and see samples
of the data understand what that is
alright this comparison is really useful
because then you can also get these
indicators that tell you hey how well
are things matched up so green
indicating things are very well matched
up that's exactly what you want blue
indicating that there's slight
mismatches that you want to address red
indicating there's something very
something significantly wrong and the
last part about this is because now data
prep knows what you want it to look like
it actually can suggest transformations
to help fix this right so in this case
I'm going to fix the effective date
I'm gonna click on that and it's gonna
tell me oh the problem with your
effective date is that your formats are
incorrect instead of right you want to
change it from day to day months to a
year you back to your year month great
that's why I do so it's as simple as
clicking on it and it will automatically
fix it now there may be cases where
we're dealing with Y datasets where you
know you're dealing with potentially
hundreds of sorry Y datasets potentially
hundreds of columns across in that
situation what you can do is switch to
the column view of data prep and it
allows you to more compactly see just
the columns it's much easier to reorder
rename columns on mass you can also
decide to remove or remove columns or
add missing ones and the whole goal of
course is then to make sure everything
matches everything's good to go and
green and validate this in the product
before you go ahead and publish it
before you send your automation all
right so let's now see this in action
city ok thanks again Shawn
screaming to come up there we go okay so
I am back in data prep and I'm in the
transformer grid and I have a different
dataset here and this is actually it
resides in GCS and it's um recently
uploaded customer data so it has some
information like their first name their
last name their account number some
employer information and many other
fields here now what I need to do with
this is I need to take this data set and
I need to append a customer details
table and bigquery so before I do that
though I know I have some manually
entered data here so I have to do some
column standardization and I need to do
that on this employer column because I
have lots of different company names
here and I'm sure you can imagine some
of the challenges with this manually
enter data if you're going to do some
aggregations and you don't have a single
standardized value so I'm going to come
to the employer column we're gonna go to
this drop-down menu and we have
standardized right here so when I choose
standardize I'm just going to show you
where that clustering option is we run a
first the first cluster to look at the
similar strings across all the rows so
we're clustering all of the rows based
on characters in common so here with
Acme Inc I see I have ten different
values so Acme Inc written ten different
times across fifty three different rows
and that's really quite a problem
sometimes so I am I mean there are
things here it's not just like
capitalization but it's also hyphens
present commas present periods present
people who embellish their company name
when they're inputting it themselves
like the quotes here so I want to get
all of these to the same value to do
that I'm gonna select them all will come
over here I'm gonna enter my new value
make it kind of simple now before I
apply this Shawn talked about running
another algorithm so we're gonna come
back to the clustering options and we're
gonna now cluster values based on
pronunciation so all of the rows that
actually sound alike and when I do that
you see we actually have a few a few
more rows show up now the nice thing
here is all I have to do is come and
click on these and as I select them the
value that standardized value that I
want is automatically put in it's that
simple I'm now going to hit apply we're
now going to choose to add this logic to
my recipe step so you can always come
back and look at this when we come back
to the transformer GUID the grid the
recipe opens up and we now have this
reusable logic so anytime we have new
data coming in we can actually use this
logic that we've already created to do
exactly the same thing so that's pretty
nice now if you remember what we want to
do with this data set so we've done our
standardization as I want to now run a
job and I'm gonna append that bigquery
table the customer details so I'm gonna
come here I'm going to choose run job
and I already have my publishing action
set up so append bigquery the customer
details I'm gonna run this in US West is
fine and I'll hit run job
oh okay look at what we have here
something's not happy with this so we
can't run the job so what I've done is I
only paid attention to the data what did
I not pay attention to I didn't pay
attention to the schema and bigquery so
I need to fix that so I'm gonna cancel
close out of this recipe now I have the
schema over here and bigquery so what I
could do is I can come down here I can
look at the schema scroll down or not
they've changed my resolution on the
screen so there's a schema down here
here we see a count number it's an
integer so we'll come back to data prep
and okay here's an account number here's
the integer or it's a string though so
I'd have to change that so I could go
back to bigquery and I could try and
look at that schema again there we go
and then back to data prep wow that's
kind of clunky not really a lot of fun I
don't really want to do that especially
for a really wide dataset so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to load that
target right here in my transformer grid
so I'm going to attach a target I'm
going to look for my customer details
target schema and I'm gonna add it so
that's pretty nice this is right from
bigquery this is the table that I want
to update and we're going to give you a
sample of the data as well and we give
you these visual cues to help you get
your that this the source data to the to
the target schema that we want now we
also have a column view which is super
helpful when you're looking at wide data
it's a bit more efficient so I go to the
I just clicked on this column view here
over here is our target over here is the
source again we have these visual cues
the first position is the account number
and it's an integer when I hover over
this blue box here it's telling you
there's a there's a matching column I
can move it and it will show you in the
source where that column is so
watch real close I just selected that
blue box and it automatically moved that
account number does anybody notice what
else it did there's a big hint it
automatically changed it to an integer
for me so I don't have to go in and do
any of that so now I'm just gonna
continue down
okay City we have all of these matches
which is fantastic
this is so easy I mean then we come down
here and we have this contract start and
it's a red box now if it doesn't
automatically detect this for me I can
choose what column and I know I have
this column one I actually know I can
see the data type is the same and I
happen to know it is the contract start
so all I'm gonna do is scroll down and
select that column 1 it automatically
renames it for me and we have nice
alignment I have two extra columns so
this is why I got that big error in
addition to the one data type difference
I'm just gonna select these again I'm
interacting with the data I get these
suggestions over here on the side I'm
gonna come down to the delete columns
because I don't want it I'm gonna choose
add we'll go back to that grid view
close out of this recipe and nicely I
can validate against my bigquery table
before I actually publish pretty awesome
now we're gonna run the job again we're
appending uswest is fine what run job
okay
so it's gonna run the job I'm easily
standardizing the data and then I
quickly use that target schema that we
loaded in the transformer grid to get my
source data ready for publication and to
bigquery so that covers the second part
well that looked like fun all you do was
just kind of clicking and it
automatically transformed everything for
you yeah I'm kind of like a video game
all right
so now we'll just wrap up coming to the
end very quickly we'll cover the topics
I'll just take aways from what we just
covered and I'll talk a little bit some
of the next steps that you
we'll be interested in so if we remember
we covered four topics for challenges
that we're going after right first was
nested data how do you expand and
extract values from that nested data and
so we saw examples of that following
that when you're dealing with data
patterns take advantage of the column
profile details and then use the
suggested transforms to actually fix
those formats you'll have to write
everything from scratch when it comes to
sanitization use multiple algorithms
build that group as much as possible so
you get the widest set the last one to
note is when you comes down to
publishing before you do that quickly
validate it make sure that your data
actually matches your target and
hopefully can solve a lot of the minor
details that you need in order to make
it successful
okay these are just a few of the
powerful techniques and transformations
that are available in cloud data prep
that help you gain insight inside your
data all through a simple easy use
interface we didn't get into it we
didn't have a chance to talk about some
of the sharing and automation
capabilities that are at par our data
prep so you can build out and maintain
your pipeline but if you're interested
in learning more we do have a booth here
it's between the server lists analytics
and machine learning zones where you can
ask data prep experts any questions you
may have as well you can sign up for our
training workshop we do these we do
these things in person and then lastly
if you want more examples things that
you've seen outside here please take a
look at the data prep community and one
last part is for the folks who actually
haven't tried cloud data prep right and
we're just here of chest as the intro
you can try it today just go to your
console and just launch data prep
directly from there it's in the Big Data
section okay with that thank you very
much
[Music]